don't fit the sport we'll change the
sport
if we don't fit the sport we'll change
this one now that can mean in any way
that can be a sudden message of
you know if we don't fit it as much as a
muslim woman or a woman
a muslim sister or a muslim brother yeah
and then
she eventually she comes back then she
comes back she's
and they were just singing and now they
transition into a
um into a cabbage
this journey this road that i travel on
it all seems crazy over the years i
picked up thousands of tagalongs
inspired by my story from a juvenile
where my clothes had holes in them
and my afro was picky to the 90s
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing shadow welcome
to this video beautiful day
and we're going to take a look at this
nike ad video
from a different perspective free
perspectives and these three
perspectives fit
beautifully with er quran ayah in surah
fatir verse
32 three things allah subhanahu wa tala
mentions
so how do these free correlation sisters
we're going to go through that
so the recent ad that was done by now i
want to make something very clear yeah
now do i blame nike not really in the
context of look mike is there to make
money
as simple as that in a capitalistic
world where everything's about
materialism and money
that's what they do they're just making
money so brothers and sisters do not be
very surprised when you see these kind
of things of a nikabi going
into a transition into another screen of
a woman if i'm saying who might be maybe
shave the head off
a bisexual transsexual or whether she
wants to identify gender neutral a piano
a guitar
a skateboard whatever she wants to or he
wants to identify himself as
so the thing is don't be surprised
because at the end they is it that
knight cares about the lgb qtbq
the letters community and the muslims
not really because nike does hijabs for
sisters
wherever money is to be made they are
there it's as simple as that so yes i
know there's some
subliminal messages in that we can't
blame that you know why out of all
people you choose a why don't you a
crushed christian woman or a jewish
woman or a jewish man
transition into that you know why not
why why why a muslim woman anyways
and i'm sure i know there's a lot of
scissors to do some good skateboarding
skills you know
uh you know i've seen some that i've
been looking at you know you see some
actually i think i saw a sister
doing some mad skills in a skateboard so
yeah there is potential there
anyways that's not my point my point is
the following now let's watch the video
i want us to look at this in three
different
angles let's be creative with our mind
let's watch it
and if we don't fit the sport we'll
change the sport
okay let's hear that again let's hear
that again it's four seconds
and if we don't fit the sport we'll
change the sport
if we don't fit the sport we'll change
this one now that could mean in any way
that can be something message of
you know if we don't fit it as much as a
muslim woman or a woman
a muslim sister or a muslim brother if
you don't fit
islam you can change islam we can see it
from the angle it could mean there can
be a certain message
why not you don't fit into it if we
don't fit the sport
we will change the sport and this is
what lgbt
is about change it's about once it's
about me myself i
like allah says in the quran have you
seen one who takes himself and his
desires has his
god so don't think worship something is
going and worship in the tree it doesn't
work like that yeah so you can be of
people who are worshiping
different things so this could be
something subliminal message of
if it if it doesn't uh what's going to
listen to again
and if we don't fit if we don't fit the
sport we'll change the sport
if you you know if islam doesn't fit to
your lifestyle change it you can change
it transition
now allah says in the quran something
very profound
allah talks about his chosen servants in
surah fatiha al-assad
said that the the his servants that he's
inherited that they've
er inherited the book the book the quran
the kitab the books have come before
yeah
the quran that they will be inheriting
it now allah talks about three types of
people now we're going to be talking
about them
and we're going to do a little mix up
we're going to do a little editing with
this video and let's get some
let's get some positivity out this video
inshallah with this verse this big
connection with this verse inshallah
we have let's take this let's put this
into perspective i'm going to have this
image now
this image is what now how does these
three individuals allah is talking about
fit into this
very image of nightcard how did it even
correlate what the hell are you talking
about what are you talking about brother
let me come to it listen carefully now
the first one allah said
are those who transgress their self so
you have a sister i'm going to play it
for you
yeah a sister in the cab yes let's
listen for ourselves
trangress in look as she gone she's in a
kaabi or this can be a brother this is
just symbolizing a righteous person i
suppose yeah
and righteousness is not out of
appearance in in in acts as well please
make that clear
and what did they do they tranquest
themselves and
they disobey allah yeah and let's
symbolize that the nikah but
is that you this you disobeying allah
his commandments yeah not actually
but the commandments allah is asking you
to do so from here we can see nakabi
transitioning into somebody who's
falling into sin still a believer
but falling into sin and promoting
certain ideologies that shouldn't be
promoted
et etc yeah so we can say the ayah first
one visually
we can say okay this fits that the next
one is what one sisters
the ones who are mediocre so those
who are you know they try their best
they fall into scene except
they come back you know they're in the
in between so let's reverse this
yeah in the context of let's show for
example
the nikabi you have she's a practicing
she falls off the team
yeah and goes on a mating yeah with this
flag and stuff etc
and then she also uh
yeah and then she eventually she comes
back then she comes back she's
she sins but she's doing mediocre yeah
okay that is how we can see it
yeah that's somebody who is practicing
but sometimes falls off
mediocre they're trying their best etc
they come back etc
okay now the third one is the ones who
outpace
they outpace they're going forward so
let's take this video and
reverse it in the context of let's put
the flag the the woman who's holding the
flag
on this side left-hand side and let's
make her transition into a nakabe
in the context of righteousness so what
is it outpacing
there might be a revert they might have
jahilia they may have just come to islam
or they were born a muslim and they were
just sinning
and now they transition into a um
into an acaba hijab in the context of
righteous deeds we're not saying the
phys like without appearance
and they outpace everybody where they
were before they leave that behind
they repent and they outpace everybody
in righteousness and they do as much
righteousness as they can
brothers and sisters this is what allah
is talking about and while
it is so amazing that allah puts these
three people into the same category of
inheritance of the quran now this is
very interesting because if you look at
the
the um to see of this you see that the
the valid opinion is that when it talks
about these three categories the ones
who sins
the ones who are mediocre and those who
outpace and do a lot of righteous deeds
the first one a lot of people accept
the position that is talking about
muslims who are sinners
but living abdullah ibn masood and a few
other companions have hold the view
that this is talking about the
disbelievers
those are disbelievers yeah so this is
the correct opinion is no they're not
the spirits they're the ones muslims are
transgressing
now it's very important because what i
shared says
something so profound and light just
humbles one down yani
our mother eyeshadow and she says that
the ones who are outpacing so the top
one outpacing others
is those at the time of the process his
companions and those who were promised
janna
he says then the second one who are
mediocre are the ones who
just fell behind them and so panel look
what she says
and she goes the ones who are
transgressed itself he goes there like
us
brothers and sisters well like isn't
that amazing that the prophet's wife
classes herself as one of those who are
kind of transgressing
so we can see that as an evidence that
it's not talking about disbelievers but
look at the humbleness of aisha
and her that she's saying that she is
one of those who transgress
in the cause she's like it's a humble
way of looking and you see this with the
companions like
he was one of the temporal misgender but
he failed he feared himself
that he's one of the hypocrites of the
monarchical when the when the revelation
came
to enlist the hypocrites brothers and
sisters
this shows humbleness attitude in the
time that we live
people of self-righteous piety arrogance
this shows you to humble yourself
brothers and sisters
this is a beautiful reminder and this is
what i took that's what i agree with
if it's at the perspective that we look
at so probably says i wanted to share
that with you inshallah please go and
read that specific verse in the quran
verse 32 it's beautiful even if you sin
brothers and sisters whatever thing you
do you are still our last chosen servant
and whoever you are whatever sin you
might be committing if it's never too
late for you to turn back
brother and sisters that's what i wanted
to say inshallah i hope you guys have
benefited leave a comment
uh in the section below inshallah tell
us a bit about how you felt uh
with this specific ad till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh